this is probably illegal but once again
I think it's my duty to share these
calls between president-elect Trump and
President Barack Obama let's take a
listen
whoa hey Barack did you hear that
I was time Person of the Year pretty
good huh
dude won honors and graduations Donnell
back beat I've officially stuck here
that the rock and Brian Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman and the home you're
thinking of people sexiest man alive ish
oh right it's still true though every
let me ask you if they fight fences
hoping he gets a shot at president well
I think the thought crosses all vice
president's mind they are next a lot I
thought so I'll have them executed just
to be you know that wall I'm gonna build
between us in Mexico yeah what if they
build tunnels underneath it well he was
pointed out that potential weaknesses
you first Jeff then I guess we'll have
to fill the tunnels with honey
certificates done you're right I'll go
in maple syrup who are all the portraits
around the White House of those our own
former president really we met women
presidents before please don't tell me
you've mistaken George Washington from
the fight oh I'm just getting ahead
I was exam which in the middle of the
night you make sure the White House
kitchen is open 24 hours of it yeah what
if I watch steak will they make me say
whatever you want really even better no
that's for Paris we can't have a
McDonald it's an endangered species
well we serve it at Merrill our code
Ethernet is fan tonight Wednesday's bald
eagle
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you